what if a sustainable person wants to
get McDonald's because they're drunk
exactly we want convenience we want
sustainability yes we want healthy food
yes not always we guys my name is Joyce
and this is my journey to zero waste Z
Roses the roses z0 today we're gonna be
trying to get fast food with no trash
zero waste
we're gonna go to three different places
where are we going guys we're going to
McDonald's Chappellet and chick-fil-a I
think they're gonna look at me like
girly okay
you came to McDonald's you really caring
about how you feeling about the
environment when you eating that double
cheeseburger that ain't healthy
can you put it in this container no man
putting zero waste I'm gonna be like why
did you get fast food then I'm kind of
excited to see if it's gonna work I
think it really is gonna depend on who's
behind the counter
what do we you don't work just gonna get
my usual drunk food I'm a double a
medium frying a frappe how many
containers do you think we need yeah
that should be enough whoo
I guess I'm gonna get a mushroom burger
because that looks like it's the only
vegetarian option you're getting yeah
I'm actually we're awake so I wanted to
know if you guys can put the food in
each container so I can't use the voices
and the fast-food workers so I'm gonna
have Aria do a dramatic reading hello oh
I think we can but I would need to ask a
manager to see if we can sorry we can't
because due to sanitary reasons okay is
there a way to get Lincoln drink I could
still charge you the drink I still just
have to give you a cup but you can fill
it up right there
no go I hope it really is a sanitary
thing and I'm excused I think we should
try another McDonald's ok this is really
a [ __ ] chance I'm teaching blacks me
we were always I can't put that inside
of them I mean yeah I could give you
guys the food and you could just put it
in there right yeah we can't put it in
there cuz we can't put anything from the
outside in the kitchen that's a health
code violation for us means our lows
won't put it
so I hear this thing about health codes
but then that applies for some major
brands and for others it doesn't like
that applies to McDonald's but it
doesn't apply to Starbucks and that's
where I get confused and also you could
put processes in place to make sure that
it's completely clean on to Japan should
always when I do it I've done intimately
before so I'm pretty sure they're gonna
do it what do you like to get a try I
get a buddy
so readable thanks okay yeah Ben
hi can I please get a burrito bowl I
don't know if I can do that but I will
ask first I'm sorry we can't we're not
allowed to take anything from the dining
room back here that's what the manager
told me sorry about that
[Music]
[Music]
how do you get fat soon normally for you
I'll bring my own container if I want
food to go
yeah but it's always at local
restaurants so I haven't tried to do
this at a fast food place I ate so much
fast food as a child though mm-hmm my
parents were young my mom had me when
she was 20 you know if you don't have a
lot of money eat a lot of fast food
growing up as a kid I lived in a food
desert you know my two Asian parents I
came to this country our neighborhood
there was enough farmers market
it was McDonald's like right across from
the library when my mom was working and
she dropped us off at the library my
parents worked their butts off for us to
be in this country and a half was at
life and then the only foods that are
available to us in the food that we
could afford were unhealthy and full of
unnatural chemicals the final Chipotle
didn't and she saw us face what I think
it's not gonna happen I have a sliver of
faith I'm gonna try acting in a very
firm way all right
all you ask
a vegetable but I'm gonna use my own
container um manager she wants to use
our own container for the box
I'm pretty sure just water you can't get
any soda you did it for me one time too
Polly you did last man in Texas
sustainability should be convenient
that's why no one does it because he's
so hard our next stop is our front of me
chick-fil-a I'm losing hope this is no
service to be able to get her to play we
got her drink we almost thought we were
gonna get it zero waste he took our
containers yeah into his side of the
window and we were so excited but he's
like his mind you said he couldn't we
came up short we didn't get any food
zero waste except for our Arnold Palmer
from chick-fil-a so she placer
sustainability winner yeah a new day a
new opportunity for zero waste you
wouldn't let the dream guy re I wouldn't
want to die all the restaurants we went
to said that they couldn't fill our own
containers because health code
prohibited that but that's false
okay it's false California health and
safety codes allow customers to bring in
clean containers but it doesn't require
restaurants to but that's why today I am
taking you to a local business okay
where we can get fast food in our own
continued because I've done it there
many many times okay that's amazing wait
what's the name of the place we're going
to zanko's chicken which is a Los
Angeles staple and their food is
delicious that sounds amazing let's go
that's let's go get tonight we have our
own container can we use our container
yes thank you you know you look like
your mom right thanks for taking your
container we did it we did it I'm
starving
hmm right goes on that it's flavor more
on the story go to local restaurants and
not chains if you want to get your food
filled up in your own container mixers
one wheel here is around $8.99 which
isn't too crazy and we were able to get
at zero waste and in under five minutes
yeah there always is good for the soul
and good for you Tommy thank you so much
for watching please comment below if you
would try this at your favorite
fast-food restaurant next week I'm gonna
make a mac and cheese but zero waste
hopefully I don't make my mother mad but
Chipola you did it for me one time time
in the car I hear the gram I improve
[Music]